one aspect of the inauguration more than
the others
uh i think gave us a preview of the
biden administration
which is after the hour hour 15 minute
ceremony up on the podium with the
speakers
biden goes over to the lincoln memorial
and they get a nice photo op of joe
biden standing
paying his homage to the lincoln
memorial our sort of
pagan temple to civic religion which
which is i'm not i'm not even using that
as a kind of a joke or a mockery that is
the purpose of the lincoln memorial is
to be a temple
to the american civic religion and
that's why lincoln's is sitting there
like zeus
and it's a greco-roman temple so biden
goes in there pays his respects there's
a cello playing
one aspect of it though that you can't
help but notice is
joe biden just issues a mandate that on
federal lands
you have to wear a mask right this is
part of his big push he wants everyone
to wear masks all the time in america
and then
then after the masks after 100 days
presumably is going to say okay you can
take your masks off we beat the virus
it's all thanks to me
not thanks to trump by the way who
handled the virus marvelously
got a vaccine out in six months really
did a great job
and did much better than the governors
no biden's going to take credit
however on federal land at the lincoln
memorial joe biden
not wearing a mask that
is that is going to be
the hallmark i think of the biden
administration is there going to be
rules and mandates
for thee but not for me
they're going to be rules that all the
deplorable bitter clingers have to play
by
but that the elites will not play by you
know
angelo codavilla who's a claremont
institute
fellow really brilliant writer he had a
piece in the american greatness
where he described the kind of cycle of
regimes and how america
more and more resembles an oligarchy
that the idea of the cycle of
regimes is that you have democracy and
then it it can decay into oligarchy and
then oligarchy
can transform into monarchy and then
monarchy can be overturned and turned
into democracy and this is kind of a
classical cycle of regimes
looking up at the people extolling the
virtues of democracy yesterday
it looks a lot like an oligarchy it does
you see all the same familiar faces and
you don't see very many
representatives of the people there and
you see all these elites playing by one
set of rules
that they that they then voiced another
set of rules on the people
that we're going to get a whole lot more
of that and nobody
nobody is going to hold biden and
company to account
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts